My name is Emily Runge, and I'm from Newton
Kansas. I graduated Newton High School in
2012, and now I'm Politics major at Hillsdale
College. This spring I'm interning at the
Asian Studies Center at the Heritage Foundation
in Washington DC for the Washington Hillsdale
Internship Program.The Washington Hillsdale
Internship Program, we
call it WHIP for short, we bring anywhere
between ten to twenty students a semester
out to DC. They take two or three classes
and they intern on the hill, at the Heritage
Foundation, really anywhere they want to.
When we find somebody coming out of college
who has some practical real world experience,
especially experience that applies to what
we do, it really sets them apart. Washington
is one of those places that kids can learn
a lot and gain a lot just from being hear
a few moths. And in that since, coming here
and having that interning experience I guarantee
will be life changing.